hey everyone eric boss here in the new
rockstars blue dungeon and we just got
our first official trailer
for denny villeneuve's dune adapted from
frank herbert's novel
that star wars stole i have been waiting
for this movie for a
very long time i'm a huge fan of
dennyville new from everything he's done
with sicario blade runner 2049
arrival we've been seeing a ton of
concept art for this movie we've been
seeing
teasers for trailer and now i got the
full trailer in front of me normally new
rockstars does in-depth frame by frame
breakdowns which we will be doing of
this trailer later this week
right now i'm just gonna rawly react to
it you guys seem to enjoy it when i did
it for the batman one even though we
were slightly unsynced and i screamed
over the word vengeance
all right here we go
there's something happening to me okay
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see oh
there's a crusade coming whoa okay so
same paula tradies here
do you often dream things that happen
just as you do
jesuit yes
the test is simple photography remove
your hand from the box
this is in the teaser and you die what's
in the box
a pain southern reference
you inherit too much power anytime they
show norway
it looks looks great
my god something none of your ancestors
learned
my father rules an entirely caledon he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you lose that
one too
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the music
i know you
oh my god
what the legend will be
of born depends on it
oh
[Music]
i must not fear
just fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
all right only i will remain
what
oh my god
oh
holy [ __ ] okay
wow all right well they are totally
doing this
uh first reactions uh here's what i'll
say danny villeneuve made a movie like
blade runner 2049 and arrival which
are amazing films beautiful
cinematography on both those films
but like you talk to general folks who
just go
see movies and they don't really know
those movies
a lot of people got really excited for
blade runner 2049 when it really was a
true sequel to the original blade runner
without remembering that the original
blade runner
is not like a crowd favorite it's a
cinematic masterpiece but it's like a
languid
moody film as 2049 was and i'm seeing a
lot of similarities with dune here
didn't evil new
master filmmaker master storyteller
clearly loves dune loves the novel
will this be a charmer that wins over
everyone who hasn't read the book or is
familiar with the series
i don't know i really don't care
honestly i've had enough of like desert
set
sci-fi stories that try too hard to win
over people
and it looks like self has oscar isaac
but yeah you're gonna hear a lot about
the word
scale but what does scale mean scale
isn't just showing
big stuff it's showing the big stuff in
relation to
the small stuff that you connect to and
it gives you that sense of love crafty
and dread that you're seeing something
that is too impossible to take all in
at once and that's what we're seeing
with those sand worms actually you know
what i'm going to
go back to some moments because i want
to point out some specific things here
so what we're seeing with
timothy chalamet here uh he's on the
desert planet arrakis that's what his
father duke
ledo atreides has inherited the
stewardship of but as they say in the
trailer that is a death trap it's some
political drama going on where the
emperor of this imperium is setting him
up to take this job
but really setting him up to have this
other rival the
harkinans come in and destroy this
family so in this what's in the box
scene this is paula tradies taking a
test with the benny jesserit
they're like this group of female
witches who have enhanced abilities
and paul is the result of like a
specific breeding program
his mother is lady jessica who's part of
this group and has
specifically breeded this result over
the course of generations and
generations so he was born with some of
these abilities
so one thing i love about this movie is
how the cast has people from pretty much
every nerd franchise you got marvel
represented with thanos and drax
uh you got dc represented with aquaman
you got star wars represented you got
mission impossible represented
and you have the greta gerwig universe
represented with a timothy charlemage
and already i'm loving like the
the crazy looking fighting where it
looks like they're able to activate
something that causes them to be able to
like phase shift so when
the blades hit you they have like a less
of a chance to strike actual flesh
because your body is kind of like
shifting around through space so i'm
loving the shot of the
dude coming out of i guess the the mud
or the merc
there i want to say that stellan
skarsgard as the head of a house
harkening
i'm kind of hoping this could be like a
liquid form of the spice melange this is
what it's all about so on
dune it's the universe's one planet that
has this precious material that they
call spice
that was the same word that they use in
star wars for drugs but its official
name is melange
and it's something that is highly highly
addictive but once you start using it it
gives you a longer lifespan gives you
heightened abilities
it enables interstellar travel because
you can do all these complicated
equations all at once in your head
and avoid obstacles as you're traveling
through space so that's why it's super
important
frank herbert used it as an analog for
oil when he wrote this in the 60s
so i'm hoping right now we're just
seeing harkening in like a bath of this
stuff like
yes like i just want to bathe in
cheesecake which is uh my spice my
melange is what gives me heightened
abilities
just woof down a cheesecake before i do
a breakdown
which i gotta get working on this frame
by frame breakdown because there's a lot
of cool like
visual detail that he's putting in all
these shots the way he's framing things
which i'm gonna break down in a trailer
breakdown separate video you're going to
see it later this week but one last
thing i want to point out
are these sand worms so these are these
colossal beasts that
guard the melange on arrakis and what i
love about them
is not only are they huge actually this
one in the final shot looks a bit
smaller than the other one we saw
devouring an entire
ship unless it's further away this might
be a little baby is the level of detail
with each of these uh what are they
hairs tendrils these things that are
going into their mouth
looks like a giant eye remember there
was that crazy shot in doctor strange
where he's like
zipping through the multiverse and he
grabs on the edge of what is his own eye
and he's like grabbing it but there's
these weird tendrils and it's kind of
this like gross textural moment
i think that iris design was definitely
intentional here with the design of
the san warm mouth all these tendrils
are like weathered down by the sand as
it's churning through it underground but
it also feels like it is
looking directly into you like the eye
of a giant staring into your soul
anytime you're animating a new beast or
trying to conceive a non-human character
you have to start with the eyes or
something that represents the eye shape
that's why they gave
wall-e those binocular lenses the eyes
are the window to the face
and just by giving the sandwich mouth
this eye design
you connect to it on a deeper level it's
very cool how the final moments of the
trailer go
from that eye to the circular shape of
the dune logo
yes it's supposed to be a planet eclipse
but it is also the portal of this
thing's face
and speaking of eclipse yes that was
pink floyd's eclipse from their album
dark side of the moon which i have
always associated as one of these just
like
drug induced trippy songs that you
declare as you're coming off of your
trip and you realize i am such a small
piece in this world there are bigger
things than me
i am just a pale blue dot floating in a
nebulous place
which is what i think dune is all about
making you feel like you're just a small
speck in this universe
but yes it does have some of that same
arthurian hero
monomyth legends that all stories do
we're about to start talking about dune
a lot more on this channel it's a very
important sci-fi property
i'm very excited for its film to come
out in december
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell to get all of our
videos as they come out
and our trailer breakdown for this
trailer when it comes out later this
week thank you for
bearing with my um nerdy and maybe a
little annoying gut reactions to these
things
but don't worry professor eric is coming
in soon and he's gonna
explain to you the deeper symbolism of
sand see you soon
bye
[Music]
you